why did you decide to come as Loki today
at the London comic-con well no he was
my favorite character in Thor when it
came out a few years ago and then again
in the Avengers so I just had to make
his armor but unfortunately there was a
small malfunction with the armor so I've
come with lady Loki instead what
happened with the armor well I had to
make out of craft foam and styrene which
sounds very technical but it's really
not it wasn't sticking and it wouldn't
fit and I was I was having trouble with
it so I thought you know fast that and
I'll I'll come later like you said so
you look fantastic you very much
what is it about Loki that's quite so
appealing I think it's the horns I mean
it does any other character have horns
quite so magnificent as lucky but
otherwise he's just a great character
I mean his emotional depth is amazing
and Tom Hiddleston plays him so well
I just love Tom Hiddleston so I had to
try and do him justice tell me a little
bit about these horns because they look
fantastic but also a little bit
precarious yeah they're a bit hard to
keep on and they're basically styrene
vases which I carved from a big block
and then I covered them with foil i
sanded them all down to make the shape
and then I covered them in clay and then
I attached them to this craft foam
headband with a lot of glue and then
eventually some screws which I drilled
him so yeah it's it's quite stable but
it's just yeah you had too much I don't
move my head - right yeah nodding or
shaking I don't have to move my head -
you people you're all mortals you're
below me I'm a god I'd like to see you
getting into the character did that
happen when the horns came on I think it
did yesterday I was here not in costume
and I was terrified today I've come and
I'm
getting all the badass yeah I'm so
impressed with those horns they dealer
actually amazing I mean did it take a
long time to do that it did it was it
was the moment the main sort of part of
the costume I knew I had to get them
right and the rest of it would sort of
fall into place so um yeah it took I
started in August and now it's the end
of October so he's taken that long and
then I had to paint it as well it was
worth it that looks great
tell me about the rest of you costume to
rest the question because of the armor
malfunction it was a bit hastily done so
I've got the cake which is just
basically green satin and I've got the
fur on top and then I've just green I'm
covered in green I don't really like
green but I'm covered in green that's
just basically her costume his costume
it's a screen okay that's what I found
in the shops green we might not like
green but you look good in green you're
suffering therefore for your arts you
don't like it yes it's the horns which
are the main thing I think so yeah I'm
suffering is it all worth it though
definitely worth it it's a great outfit
here I've never been before so this is
my first time cosplaying and my first
time actually here so yeah it's a really
good experience and everyone's in
costume I mean if you're not in costume
you kind of stand out so yeah it's
really good would you recommend it to
other people and what should they know
about doing it if they're doing it for
the first time I would definitely
recommend it I mean it's just great fun
and everyone's so so nice about it even
if you don't think it's very good
everyone is so so welcoming and I think
for the first time try and work with
bases so this top is just a green sort
of stretchy tarp I bought and I didn't
make it from scratch obviously so when
you're trying for the first time try and
use bases which is a basic sort of
clothing which is the same shape as what
you want because it's a lot easier and
then you can just sew on top
did you have any other help or how did
you come up with the idea of house for
the horns together I kind of just went
with it there's a lot of stuff on the
internet and people have tried to make
Loki's horns before and and craft foam
is the general because it's lights I
mean they're not really heavy so that's
I just sort of went with it
I made the shape and then had to attach
them with a lot of glue and I screwed
the meaning of eventually so yeah it's
just working paper a lot because that
really helps and then you can build in
craft foam and all that stuff it really
has her templates definitely put you at
all craft TV for this really I mean I've
never made a costume before and I've
never cosplayed before I mean compared
to some of the talent here I mean
nothing but I try my best so that's what
it's about I think as long as you try
your best
yeah absolutely you can see your
absolute you have charlie red so I'm
totally a tour of your costume though a
whole is a fantastic you look amazing
you're not nothing absolutely not
now what is it talking about Loki about
Tom Hiddleston why do you think Tom
Hiddleston plays that role so well I
don't know what it is about Tom Peterson
he's such a great actor and I think he
really understands Loki I mean Loki's
not just a bad guy I mean he's a bad guy
he's done some terrible things he's not
just that guy he's got a lot of depth to
him you know he came from such a
horrible childhood with his brother and
all that all the things he watched in
the movie and I think Tom really gets
that I think he really understands it
and he can use it and I'm in his
interviews he always says about not
knowing but he's acting he always has to
become that character I think that Rose
really helped him because he really
understands Loki so who I think I think
that's great that's what I like about
him have you really enjoyed the movie
store and Avenger so far and Ally
definitely I can't wait until Iron Man 3
I saw the trailer the other day
and thought ooze coming out soon say
yeah cut wait what would you like to see
happen in Thor - oh I think I'd like
somehow Loki to get his Redemption not
straightaway because I don't think that
would work for the character not you
know you'll forgive him Loki it's fine
but I'd like him to somehow work to
redeem himself with Thor and Asgard and
belong again I think that would be nice
of him what do you think you'd have to
do to get that Redemption do you think I
don't know either by Thor all the
pop-tarts in the world or just I don't
know somehow someone needs to understand
why he did what he did and then I think
he can work to be forgiven so maybe he
could join the Avengers to fight crime
because you know he's magic he's got
loads of stuff he couldn't eat he's got
skills he could be fine so maybe that
maybe that what happened I don't know
maybe Avengers - yes exactly
Loki will be there it would be the
mascot you can have a little Avengers
flag it'll be great I'm having this idea
I think you should put this to just read
and I definitely should I mean knowing
jars from series like Firefly he's gonna
do something horrible because he always
does he always kills off your best
character bit so I'm praying that Loki
gets saved some mouth
let's all join hands with you and let's
pray that day oh it's been lovely just
feet you don't cry enjoy the rest of the
day you very much
you